Herr Asselborn jetzt haben wir die
Gelegenheit zu sprechen über das was auf
diesem NATO-Gipfel konkret beschlossen
werden soll reicht das um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen es gibt ja schon einiges an
Kritik das ist nicht reicht was hier
heute auf der Tagesordnung steht
ich glaube wir haben uns viel Mühe
gegeben sie wissen dass 2018
aber kein Datum
wir müssen mehr geben und dieses Meer
haben wir vor haben wir vorbereitet
heißt ja dass wir diesen NATO Ukraine
Rad kreieren das ist kein Rad wo jetzt 1
+ 32 ist oder 32 + 1 das sind 33 Länder
also die Ukraine ist voll
gleichberechtigt um sein verständlich
dann zu reden über die
interrupterabilität zwischen der Ukraine
auch militärisch gesehen und der NATO
über gemeinsame Manöver aber ich glaube
auch dass man hier reden muss schon über
die kommende
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa sie
wissen dass
ich bin 19 18 Jahre Außenminister und
unser Ziel war immer mit Russland etwas
hinzubekommen und das ist jetzt
zusammengebrochen es ist jetzt gegen
Russland leider für das werkstelligen
ist es ist gegen Russland sagen sie auf
der anderen Seite die Ukraine fühlt sich
nicht ausreichend immer noch unterstützt
können Sie was Konkretes sagen zum
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine oder auch zu
diesen Sicherheitsgarantien das klingt
ja alles noch etwas nebulös also was die
Daten angeht so soll man wirklich sehr
vorsichtig sein sowohl was die
Europäische Union angeht als auch die
NATO wir würden sehr sehr viele Menschen
enttäuschen
darum die die Ukraine weiß glaube ich
dass sie nicht zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ab morgen mit die Zeit kann der der NATO
solange dieser militärischen Konflikt
dauert denn das würde ja heißen aufgrund
von Artikel 5 dass die NATO mit Russland
in Krieg wäre und was das heißt für den
Planeten das brauche ich nicht zu
erklären und das weiß auch wir müssen
jetzt nicht nur der Ukraine sagen wir es
geht schon das machen wir schon sondern
ein Gremium schaffen wir das gemacht
haben die wo zusammengearbeitet wird
über die Zukunft eben der Sicherheit in
Europa das ist das eine das zweite ist
wir werden weitermachen genau wie bis
jetzt noch intensiver mit der
militärischen Hilfe auch die ja die
Ukraine braucht um sich zu wehren
aufgrund von Artikel 51 der Schachter
der Vereinten Nationen gegen die
Angriffe Russlands weil ich hat jeder
gesagt am Tisch solange das notwendig
ist stehen wird zur Verfügung wäre
Europäische Union werden Kräuter die
Sanktionen vertiefen und das ist das was
wir tun können wir haben natürlich auch
schon gesprochen über den Wiederaufbau
der Ukraine wo die Ukraine sich auf die
Nachbarländer und auf die EU Länder
verlassen kann dass hier massiv Hilfe
kommen wird aber wir sind in einer Lage
und eine Situation noch immer in der
Ukraine leider wo in dieser
militärischen Auseinandersetzung wir nur
aufgrund der unoschachter wie ich jetzt
gesagt habe helfen können dass die
Ukraine sich wehren kann es gibt keine
Zauberformel wo man sagen kann jetzt ist
die Ukraine ab morgen Mitglied der NATO
und alles ist gut das ist alles ist im
Sinne der Ukraine
ich glaube das ist sehr wichtig dass
auch morgen selenski kommt der Präsident
das man auch von allen Seiten vom ganzen
Tisch in das erklären kann selenski wird
ja dann am Abend essen dabei sein und
morgen bei dem ersten Mal bei dem NATO
Ukraine Rat der dann ins Leben gerufen
wird das wirkt für ihn ja wie eine Art
Trostpflaster muss man so sagen deshalb
noch mal die Nachfrage wenn man wartet
bis der Krieg zu Ende ist hat dann Putin
in der Hand wann die Ukraine
naturmitglied wird also sie stellen mir
Fragen sie haben das Recht natürlich
aber ich stelle Ihnen die Gegenfrage
weil ich ja gesagt habe was
geschieht mit der Ukraine was geschieht
mit Europa was geschieht mit der Welt
wenn wir morgen ein Krieg haben Russland
gegen die Ukraine und das hätten wir
aufgrund von Artikel 5 darum man kann
die Frage nicht so stellen man kann nur
schauen was kann man tun mehr als dem
den Willen ausdrücken sondern auch ein
Gremium schaffen wo wo NATO und Ukraine
zusammen sitzen und schauen wie sie
ja wie wie einer dem anderen oder vor
allem die die die Natur weiter
militärisch helfen kann als
Mitgliedstaaten der NATO unter der
Artikel 51 der der Vereinten Nationen
und natürlich auch humanitäre Hilfe
weiter zu führen und alle Hilfe die
gebraucht wird das wir da Garantien
geben dass das auch geschieht es gibt es
gibt keine wie soll ich sagen es gibt
keine Zauberformel wo wir das eine und
das andere miteinander bekommen dann
eine letzte Frage zu Präsident erdogan
hat er im Vorfeld ja nun gesagt er wolle
EU-Mitglied werden sonst wird das nichts
mit dem NATO-Beitritt Schwedens ist da
jetzt zurückgerudert hat er diesen
NATO-Gipfel geschadet und wann wird die
Türkei EU-Mitglied ja also zu allererst
das eine hat überhaupt nichts mit dem
anderen zu tun und das kam am Nachmittag
gestern so rüber wie wenn das jetzt der
brechen wäre das ist ja nicht so dann
ich weiß nicht wie das dann alles wieder
zurück genommen wurde von Erde aber man
muss ja auch sich überlegen warum sollte
die Türkei ein Problem haben wenn
Schweden Mitglied der NATO werden will
Antwort der Türkei ist Terrorismus
gut ein Jahr lang hat jetzt Türkei
blockiert heute hat jeder im fetisiert
ihre rückwünscht dass er nicht mehr
blockiert durch das manchmal in der
Politik aber Präsident Erdogan der ist
ein Meister in diesen Strategien das
heißt wann ist Schweden dann
naturmitglied aus ihrer Sicht Schweden
das kann jetzt sehr schnell gehen das
ist ja das hat auch kein ob das jetzt
nur einen Monat dauert oder zwei oder
drei das Wichtigste war das auf diesem
Gipfel die Entspannung sagen wir mal
zustande kamen zustande herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch